die zeit keine frage die ist wichtig
aber letzten endes ist eine sekunde ja
auch nur eine sekunde oder derzeit
keinen millimeter weiter ende der
geschichte oder fehlanzeige
wir stehen kurz vor einem großen
durchbruch in der zeitmessung einer
revolution die unsere navigation unsere
finanzmärkte und die geschwindigkeit
unseres internets verändern wird
eine erfindung mit deren hilfe wir
vielleicht die grundlegenden rätsel
unseres planeten entschlüsseln können
ich spreche von optischen uhren wie die
funktionieren wie sie im vergleich zu
atomuhren funktionieren und alles
drumherum das erkläre ich euch heute
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
und vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren um kein neues video zu
verpassen
[Musik]
früher aber zeit etwas sehr subjektives
nicht nur in dem sinne den einstein
meinte jeder ort hat er seine eigene
zeit gemessen am sonnenstand auf die
einheitliche zeit wie wir sie heute
kennen einigte man sich zwar schon 1884
doch unsere heutige technik zur
zeitmessung definiert erst seit 1967 die
sekunde und zwar mit hilfe der
quantenphysik in einer atomuhr der kern
einer atomuhr sind ein quarz oszillator
mikrowellen aussendet und ein detektor
der diese zählt nach einer festgelegten
anzahl von mikrowellen schwingungen
schaltet der detektor die uhr um eine
sekunde weiter
und wenn quartz oszillatoren immer alle
gleich und immer verlässlich konstant
arbeiten würden dann wäre die atomuhr
damit auch schon fertig doch das tun sie
leider nicht deswegen gibt es eine
kontrollinstanz die cäsium atomen
soweit wir wissen immer alle gleich sind
sie werden in einem ofen aus gedampft
und durch ein vakuum geschickte so dass
sie kaum noch störeinflüssen ausgesetzt
sind aufgrund ihrer quanteneigenschaften
können sie zu diesem zeitpunkt zwei
verschiedene sogenannte energiezustände
haben wenn ihr darüber mehr erfahren
wollt dann schaut euch gerne meine video
reihe zum thema quanten an
da erklärt das ganze nochmal in vielmehr
detail tiefe mit hilfe eines magneten
werden nur die atome mit dem niedrigeren
energie zustand in das mikrowellen feld
weitergeleitet hier war waren konstant
die wellen durch die den takt der uhr an
geben
sind diese in einem ganz bestimmten
schwankungsbereich der zu den atomen
passt dann interagieren sie mit ihnen
und genau das machen sich die forscher
zunutze denn jedes element in unserem
universum hat mehrere ganz bestimmte
schwingungs frequenzen bei denen ihre
elektronen ihren quantenphysikalischen
energiezustand ändern
also stellen die forscher die
schwingungen der mikrowellen so ein dass
sie genau einige dieser frequenzen bei
den c sie um atom treffen und möglichst
viele von ihnen ihren zustand wechseln
ich kann man sich einmal glaube ich auch
einfach vorstellen als übergang zwischen
zwei elektronischen zustand
das hier ist dr huntemann von der
physikalisch technischen bundesanstalt
in braunschweig kurz pcb und er hat mir
vor ort alles gezeigt und mir alles
erklärt was ich über atomuhren wissen
wollte so wie man das aus der schule
kennt das man den grundzustand in den
schalen modell hat und einen
elektronisch angeregten zustand bei dem
das elektron auf eine höher liegende
schale angerechnet wird dann ist es der
energie unterschied zwischen diesen
beiden zustand und dieser dieser energie
unterschied wer lässt sich übersetzen in
der frequenz und die frequenz ist eben
das was wir extrahieren möchten wir
möchten am ende aus dem atom
herausbekommen oder von atomen möchten
wir wissen welche frequenz schmeckt dem
atom am besten welche ist die zu dem
übergang gehörende frequenz wenn der
quartz oszillator und damit die uhren
nun aus dem takt kommt dann bemerkten
die forscher das denn dann passt die
frequenz nicht mehr zu den atomen
sie schmeckt ihnen nicht mehr und es
wechseln nicht mehr möglichst viele von
ihnen ihren energiezustand das bemerkt
dann einen detektor am anderen ende und
justiert die mikrowellenstrahlung so
nach dass sie wieder im takt geht ein
anzeigegerät leitet dann aus dieser
mikrowellen frequenz die uhrzeit ab und
so haben wir eine ziemlich verlässliche
zeitmessung das jetzt natürlich etwas
vereinfacht und es gibt verschiedene
varianten von atomuhren aber das ist das
grobe prinzip die zeit die unsere uhren
heute anzeigen ist mit 400 solcher
atomuhren und der erdrotation
abgeglichen in deutschland seien die ptb
uns die aktuelle zeit per funk und per
internet und dort habe ich auch nils
interviewt in der sagenumwobenen uhren
halle
dieser raum ist nämlich nicht nur
komplett mit kupfer von der außenwelt
abgeschirmt der ganze raum hat auch ein
von der außenwand getrenntes
tonnenschweres fundament damit keine
erschütterungen in der umgebung die
uhren aus ihrem takt bringen
denn deutschland trägt tatsächlich circa
50 prozent zur internationalen welt zeit
bei die hälfte der welt zeit wird in
diesem einen raum gemacht und ich durfte
da einfach so rum laufen das war schon
ziemlich cool ich habe ich gefragt was
wohl passiert wäre wenn ich da aus
versehen über den stecker gestolpert
wäre
aber zurück zu den atomuhren und der
frage warum wir an optischen uhren
überhaupt forschen
die simple antwort 9 milliarden
schwingungen in einer sekunde zu zählen
reicht den forschern nicht
es soll noch präziser gehen so wie man
fotos in dem man mehr pixel auflösen
möchte versuchen sie auch die zeit immer
feiner aufzulösen
ein vorteil davon ist dass die
fehlerquote sinkt wenn man eine
milliarde pixel in einer reihe hat und
man vergisst ein
dann ist der bildfehler größer als wenn
man eine billiarde pixel in einer reihe
hat und einer fehlt und genau so ist es
auch bei den uhren die durch die feinere
auflösung immer verlässlicher wir haben
ich würde sagen dass die erfahrung zeigt
dass je schneller die uhr tickt desto
genauer wird die uhr wenn man an der
sonnenuhr denkt die einmal pro tag
rotiert dann ist sie sicherlich ungenaue
als eine schnell schwingender quarzuhr
genauso ist es bei den optischen uhren
gegenüber den klassischen atomuhren so
eine optische uhr schwingt ungefähr
100000 mal schneller als die klassische
mikrowelle natur der eine vorteil ist
diese besondere genauigkeit auf der
anderen seite sind diese uhren sehr sehr
stabil das heißt wir können in viel
kürzerer zeit gleich genaue messungen
machen eine menge bereiche unseres
lebens würden davon stark profitieren
unser gps zum beispiel dass gerd
umspannende netz dass wir für die
navigation nutzen hierfür umkreisen
zahlreiche satelliten die die erde und
senden dauerhaft ihre position und einen
zeit coach unser handy kann dann aus der
dauert die das signal gebraucht hat bis
es bei muttern gekommen ist errechnen
wie weit es vom satelliten entfernt ist
zusammen mit den signalen von weiteren
satelliten kann es so metergenau tree
engagieren wo auf der erde ist sich
gerade befindet und je exakter unsere
gps-empfänger nun wissen wie viele
bruchteile einer sekunde zwischen dem
senden und dem empfang des signals
vergangen sind desto genauer können sie
ihre position bestimmen statt meter
genau können wir mit optischen atomuhren
zentimeter genau wissen wo wir uns
gerade befinden
vorausgesetzt dass alle anderen
komponenten in dieser kette wie zb
unsere gps empfänger ebenfalls ein
upgrade erhalten für geografen und
stadtplaner ist das sehr wichtig aber
auch für uns kann das praktisch sein
in zukunft könnten navis im auto wissen
auf welcher spur ich gerade fahre und
das ich eigentlich auf einer ganz
anderen sein sollte um noch rechtzeitig
abzubiegen
auch die finanzmärkte und die
datenübertragungs netzwerke arbeiten
bereits jetzt mit bruchteilen von
sekunden um datenpakete zu verschicken
oder ob transaktionen abzuwickeln
die feiner sich eine sekunde unter
teilen könnten desto schneller können
doch sie arbeiten
die telekommunikation funktioniert mit
immer höheren bandbreiten immer höheren
frequenzen immer dichter gepackten
netzen da wird es auch über kurz oder
lang dazu kommen dass man noch höhere
genauigkeit bei den atomuhren die die
das rückgrat bild und dieser system
braucht sogar ein stein selbst wäre mit
sicherheit restlos begeistert von noch
präziseren uhren denn er seine berühmte
allgemeine relativitätstheorie besagt
dass zeit abhängig ist von der stärke
des gravitations potenzials also der
nähe zu einer großen masse zum beispiel
der erde je näher man dieser masse ist
und je größer die masse ist desto
langsamer vergeht die zeit im vergleich
zu einem von dieser masse entfernten
punkt man selbst merkt davon zunächst
nichts und forscher haben diesen
zusammenhang hier auf der erde bereits
nachweisen können eine uhr auf einem
hohen berg geht tatsächlich schneller
als eine auf meereshöhe
wenn man die zeit noch exakter einteilen
könnte könnte man noch genauer sagen wo
sie schneller und wo sie langsam agiert
und somit die höhe noch exakter messen
was tatsächlich eine sehr interessante
methode ist um höhen zu messen indem man
die zeit stoppt doch nicht nur für
praktische vermessungs vorhaben sind
optische uhren ein fortschritt
wissenschaftler hoffen sogar mit extrem
genauen optischen uhren überprüfen zu
können ob naturkonstanten wirklich so
konstant sind wie wir glauben
okay das klingt alles mega gut ich bin
dabei wie können wir es also schaffen
unsere uhren noch genauer zu machen
im grunde genommen funktioniert eine
optische uhr sowie eine klassische
atomuhr es gibt den oszillators der die
wehren aus sendet ein empfänger der sie
zählt und eine atomare kontrollinstanz
die bemerkt wenn der sendende oszillator
nicht mehr im ausgewählten takt ist nur
dass das hier alles etwas komplexer ist
da der oszillator ein laser ist dessen
frequenz schwingt viel schneller als die
des mikrowellen oszillators daher
brauchen wir erstmal andere atome als
csi um die wir mit den laser wellen
beschießen um festzustellen ob der
oszillator auch im richtigen takt bleibt
diese müssen auf die deutlich höheren
frequenzen des lasers reagieren
es gibt hier zwar bereits mehrere
vielversprechende kandidaten aber noch
keinen gewinner auf die man sich
geeinigt hat was sie aber alle können
ist auf das signal des lasers in einen
anderen quantenzustand überzugehen
diese optische übergänge sind
typischerweise quantenmechanisch
verboten das heißt sie würden spontan
nicht schnell passieren
diese übergänge regen wir an und fragen
danach das atom ob es angeregt wurde
oder nicht
und die information ob es angeregt wurde
oder nicht liefert uns informationen
darüber wie wir den laser in seiner
frequenz nach stellen sollen das sind
sozusagen diese beiden elemente die das
optische frequenz normal bilden
anschließend müssen wir die frequenz in
etwas zählbares übertragen und dafür
nutzen wir den frequenzkamm der
sozusagen die dritte komponente der
optischen mördern bildet denn eines der
größten probleme von optischen uhren ist
dass wir ihre hohen frequenzen nicht
elektronisch zählen können sie sind
tatsächlich zu schnell für uns daher
gibt es am ende des aufbaus sogenannte
frequenz käme diese erzeugen mit ganz
kurzen laserpulsen einen kamm aus
regenbogenfarbenen optischen linien die
mit extrem hoher genauigkeit immer
denselben abstand zueinander aufweisen
so kann man die frequenz einer
lichtwelle sehr präzise ermitteln
denn wenn der uhren laser auf diese
lichtlinien feld lassen sich seine
wellen mit denen der lichtstrahlen
vergleichen dabei interferieren sie zu
einer neuen dritten frequenz die niedrig
genug ist um sie zu messen
und was dann folgt ist einfache
mathematik da die neue messbare frequenz
10 das ergebnis aus - b ist und ich weiß
welche frequenz und welche ziel haben
kann ich einfach ausrechnen welche
frequenz b haben muss b ist hier unser
uhr laser das was wir herausfinden
wollen was der frequenz kam und c ist
die neue frequenz auf diese weise können
wir die ultraschnelle frequenz des
lesers ermitteln obwohl wir sie gar
nicht direkt messen können und daraus
lassen sich dann auch sekunden errechnen
optische uhren machen das was
mikrowellen uhren können nur genauer und
perspektivisch hofft man natürlich
entsprechend der übergangsfrequenz zu
gewinnen
die übergangs begrenzt ist ungefähr
100000 mal so groß wenn die übergangs
begrenzt hunderttausend mal so groß ist
würde man sich hunderttausend mal so
viel genauigkeit wünschen
das ist natürlich noch ein entfernen das
ziel der zeit hat man ungefähr ein
faktor 100 mehr genauigkeit mehr
stabilität
auch eine tägliche zeit die von
optischen uhren definiert wird ist noch
nicht realität
dafür müsste das internationale gremium
für messeinheiten erst einmal neu
definieren was eine sekunde ist dann
könnte man natürlich die sekunde besser
messen als es jetzt möglich ist das ist
in der diskussion
typischerweise sind aber optische uhren
eben immer noch gegenstand den
forschungslaboren und noch nicht im
markt angekommen und deswegen ist es aus
meiner sicht derzeit noch verfrüht
wenn neue definitionen zu tätigen
außerdem ist es so dass wenn man so eine
neue definition macht müsste man sich
für einen der kandidaten entscheiden
und derzeit gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene atome die übergänge bieten
mit denen man eine optische uhr
realisieren kann
ok es dauert also noch ein bisschen bis
unsere zeitmessung auf das nächste level
gehoben werden kann
aber die tests dafür laufen schon die
ptb hat mehr als testläufe für höhen
messungen mit optischen uhren gestartet
und die firma menus systems hat einen
frequenzkamm entwickelt der erfolgreich
ins all geflogen ist die teilergebnisse
sind positiv wir können uns also auf
bessere zeiten freuen
und das ist auch ein perfekter übergang
um mich beim endo systems für die
unterstützung bei diesem video hier zu
bedanken
vielen dank michael may der
geschäftsführer von windows systems hat
es mir ermöglicht zur ptb nach
braunschweig zu fahren und dieses video
hier zu produzieren
vielen dank dafür danke auch an nils
huntemann in der mir in der heiligen
kupfer getäfelten turnhalle alles über
atomuhren erklärt und gezeigt hat für
menowin ich übrigens auch mein erstes
video auf englisch produzieren das ist
einfach dass hier noch einmal übersetzt
wenn euch das gerne ansehen wollt oder
weiterleiten wollen vielleicht an
englische freunde dann findet ihr einen
link dazu unten in der video
beschreibung denkt you very much
ansonsten wie immer
danke fürs zuschauen state warriors
hattrick